we have the most medicated generation of
children in human history and our
nation's Association of Pediatricians is
trying to urge more medicating meanwhile
they missed the entire obesity epidemic
they missed sugar addiction as the
driver obese of obesity we have a system
that's playing whack-a-mole with late
stages instead of addressing underlying
problems
Jesse is there anything else you'd like
to share with the audience about what Dr
McCary was just saying that everything
is about money now is that doctors just
want to operate they want to prescribe
pills they're not trying to prevent
anything from happening the sicker this
country gets the more profitable these
companies are whether we're fat whether
we're depressed pills surgeries
they want to do tummy tucks for
six-year-olds they want to do sex change
Ops for six-year-olds it's not like oh
let's wait and see how this turns out or
if you know maybe you're a little chunky
run some laps eat some greens no let's
do a 450 000 invasive surgery on a child
and they're saying that that there's not
going to be any repercussions to that
and then also they feed you these
horrible unhealthy Foods sugar processed
carbs they tell you it's good for you
the new food chain came out new food
pyramid it's a scam they say that for us
in many Wheats is healthier than a fried
egg and then they wonder why people get
fat and then they over operate and we're
all left to be victims So to that point
judge Aaron Kelly who's the co-director
of the Center for Pediatric obesity at
the University of Minnesota said that
obesity isn't a lifestyle problem it's
predominantly emerges from biological
factors and we all know that biology
does play a role in this but is taking
out the decision making things like
going to physical education classes and
what you eat look look I'm not a doctor
but I can tell you this this generation
of kids is looking at their phones
they're watching television their couch
potatoes they haven't gone to school for
two years they don't get involved in
phys ed in school it's not even required
anymore and then when they do go to
school the food that they have I was
reading some of the studies the food
they have at school has more sugar in
like 69 percent of the cases than it
should have I'm not talking about
desserts I'm talking about the regular
food and the amazing part of it is that
um even KFC and Campbell's Soup refuse
to buy the same meats that the
Department of Agriculture allows to be
given to kids in school so in addition
to sugar addiction you've got bad food
being given to them fast food and then
it's the Quick Fix generation how dare
you say to somebody you know what I'll
give you uh you can take over you
whatever they're taking for to lose
weight with a uh with it with a needle
and what does does that mean now a 13
year old girl who may be prone to
anorexia is going to say I really want
to have this I really want to get thin
the whole thing is out of control it's
like everything else that we do
everybody wants to be beautiful they
want to be thin or their version of
beautiful beautiful and the people in
charge are not protecting them them
we've got to just get them off their
butts get them outside and then if there
are biological issues deal with those
Dana well one of the things I was
thinking about was when I went to the
Reagan Defense Forum in California in
December I did a panel talking about
readiness in our military and one of the
things that's happening at recruiting
offices all across the country is say
that you're 18 you're graduating from
high school but you don't think you want
to go to college and the military might
be for you the the percentage of people
who cannot pass the physical fitness
test is really high and they've lowered
standards a little bit but they can't
lower them anymore because if they lower
them anymore then you could put somebody
on the battlefield that isn't ready or
isn't able and then if they get hurt of
course then one that's terrible for that
person and then that's a disabled person
you have to take care of them for the
rest of their life or they might die or
they might cause other people to die
it's a really big problem I don't know I
don't know the answer but I also saw
that 22 percent of schools have no
physical education at all
just horrible it's hard whatever
happened to let's move remember that
let's move Michelle did that not stick
she did she did what she could she'd be
moving a little bit more it was their
time to leave the White House Greg all
right well you know what what the real
danger is the loss of Jolly children
when I grew up the fat kids were jolly
you know you start to start surgically
removing that fat you're going to lose
all those Jolly Jolly kids look I hate
children everybody knows that I hate
ugly children more I think we should
lean into the surgery if the kids got
zits do a facelift right if he's pudgy
do the Lipo he's short insert the bolts
lengthen his legs red hair shave it
insert black hair follicles you want an
athletic look get some Peck implants why
not why not do it right the American
Academy of Pediatrics when did it turn
into an engine of child abuse when you
look at some of the stuff that's coming
out of these these organizations it's
disgusting nobody is there to defend
these kids anymore but
We're All To Blame at this I when I was
home over the holidays I was binge
watching friends and the commercials the
selection of commercials tells you
everything about the American system and
why the sustained problem of obesity is
actually intended right so the first
commercial and the break
succulent Pizza Hut the next prescript
the next commercial a prescription for
weight loss after that McDonald's after
that Weight Watchers after that Dunkin
Donuts after that commercial for
diabetic medications type 2 medications
so what we have is one thing feeding
after the other you have the food
company that's in bed with these
government agencies you have the drug
companies that are in bed with these
agencies they don't want to say bad
things about anything that's why sugar
got a free pass and everybody went after
protein right and fat and it was
actually it was sugar sugar but these
cereal companies these are huge
companies the corn syrup all of this
stuff so the commercials if just watch
the commercials and you will not you
will be you will unsee it you will see
you will see cereal you will see uh
weight loss you will see Pizza I wonder
what the next commercial is on the five
well you'll see my pillow and then
you'll see proof of Life whatever that
stuff is